was geht hier ist max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video
es wird die hölle kann ich euch jetzt
schon sagen denn je spiel minecraft mit
controller und wir spielen minecraft
jump league ich habe echt schiss weil
ich weiß dass es die absolute hölle und
ungefähr die größtmögliche challenge in
ganz minecraft ist ich habe keine ahnung
wie das geht
wirklich ich weiß buchstäblich nicht mal
wie man richtig sprintet mit dem teil
einfach zweimal den controller vor mehr
weiß ich gar nicht weiß wie man es nie
so viel weiß ich man musste ihn ein
controller eindrücken ihr habt alle
gesagt spiel dass max und deshalb tue
ich das jetzt das aber wie doppel b
sprinten leute das wird die absolute
hölle
ich bin gespannt ob ich durch erste
modul schaffe okay ich halte man hier
den controller so dass ihr dass ihr
aussehen könnt dass ich tatsächlich mit
controller spiele der wird heute noch
fliegen habe ich das gefühl aber noch
kann ich mich beschweren na ja gut es
ist schon extrem kacke gerade aber was
soll ich denn machen
a nice so weit war ich noch nie was soll
ich denn machen wir die ganzen leiter
sprünge kommen an zack nicht nice nice
glaub ich muss jetzt einfach mal mit
maus bluten
welcher klub überhaupt keine ahnung wie
das geht mit dem controller alter
schwede schlagen die recht gut ich komme
einfach nicht erst jetzt richtig den
ersten titel durchgekommen und dann
passiert das dann passiert sowas
das gibt's doch nicht wie gibt es eine
sprint raste jedoch es gibt kein sprint
dass ich glaube muss zweimal diesen
controller
dieses links bei uns hier muss man
zweimal vor drücken damit man überhaupt
sprinten kann
und gott komm schon
es ist schon jetzt schon ich muss
einfach ein modul scharfen messer
zufrieden
dann werde ich wahrscheinlich komplett
untergehen im zweiten teil leute ich
weiß gar nicht wollt ihr überhaupt sowas
zehn manchmal gerade echt ein bisschen
sorgen um dieses video
ob das überhaupt irgendwie was werden
kann boah krass zu sprengen
cva darüber zu führen wie es ein kollege
der hier vorne hat auch seine struggles
genauso wie wir das gut da sehen wir die
einzigen aber ich nehme es mal anders er
nicht mit controller spielt stop stop
what the [ __ ] buffer ich werde es nie
kanada dass ich nicht gegen die strömung
ankommen kann hier das ok moment man
kann jetzt nicht im wasser schwimmen
irgendwie durch so ein komischer leute
da ist der erste checkpoint 6,1
geschafft okay das wird die hölle
das wird die absolute härte gehört wie
sein hemd irgendwie an die ecke man kann
es an die ecke ganz an die ecke warum
fand ich runter ich habe dir doch gar
nicht berührt oder diesen einspruch habe
noch nie geschafft
ja da ist das ding da ist das verdammte
ding und wir nehmen uns einfach die
nächste kiste wir haben ein schwert wir
haben naja
mehr oder weniger vollständige rüstung
das sieht sehr wenig versprechend aus
warum schreibt ihr das in die kommentare
dass ich so was spielen soll seid ihr
eigentlich komplett verrückt das macht
einen kaputt ohr bisher so was was sie
für mich so was
das ist jetzt aber nicht da oder wo es
okay ich dachte es wäre es werden
während fans jump also einen sound
sprung aber ist es zum glück nicht
all das wird richtig schwierig da ist
das ding komm schon
ich fühlte krass welche war ich ein
bisschen hinbekomme und modul 2 mein
gott das hätte ich niemals erwartet
ich hätte niemals gedacht dass ich über
ein modul rauskomme die zeit ist um
ich dachte ich mir irgendwie gut und die
anderen ok ich muss das erst muss ich
mal kurz so vornehmen
okay gibt der ähnlich viel zu erkunden
und wir spielen ja soviel dazu können
ein bisschen rücksicht nehmen nein
ich winke habt ihr gemacht man leute ich
werde jetzt einfach rennen und wir
einfach nur einen kill machen ich habe
auch keine ahnung wie man bei 5 macht
ist es so schwierig zu wein kraft zu
spielen wo nicht das machen
ab ins wasser nein was warum schreibt
die mir auf twitter ich soll das spielen
dieses ding gehört verboten beim blick
wirklich ich hab mich ich habe mich
wirklich so zusammengerissen und so
konzentriert wie es noch nie habe bei
minecraft spielen und ich habe mir echt
mühe gegeben ich hab mir gedacht ich
kann das irgendwie einigermaßen schaffen
und einigermaßen irgendwie was reißen
also pvp kannst du komplett vergessen
du kannst alles komplett vergessen es
ist die hölle los so dieses ding com
jetzt dahinter und ich würde sagen ich
beende diese aufnahme und werde jetzt
irgendwie ein stressabbau ball oder so
was mir holen und dann ja schreibt mir
nie wieder solche dingen die vorschläge
die vorschläge schreiben
das ist ziemlich kurz aber ich bin sauer
das war echt kacke aber auch lustig dem
ist du okay bis anschließt